er ist noch da oder wieder donald trump
lässt sich von anhängern in florida
feiern
nach umfragen wollen 77 der republikaner
eine wichtige rolle für ihn in der
partei für 55 prozent der befragten es
sogar gewalt als mittel gerechtfertigt
wenn konservative werte unterzugehen
drohen
eigentlich müsste das auch die
republikaner im senat besorgen denn die
ankläger im management prozess zeigten
neben erdrückende beweismaterial auch
ein video in dem trump anhänger ihr ziel
unmissverständlich formulieren
wir zerstören die gop gemeint ist die
grand old party also die republikanische
partei trotzdem stimmen am ende nur
sieben republikaner für schuldig 43
andere sagen sich nicht los vom trump
ismus obwohl selbst ihr anführer im
senat tram eigentlich für schuldig hält
präsident rams taten vor dem aufstand
waren eine schändliche schändliche
verletzung seine amtspflicht
donald trump schlägt zurück mit
mcdonnell werde die partei künftig nur
noch verlieren er seinen mürrischer
missmutiger griesgrämiger politischer
heini der parteiinterne bürgerkrieg hat
begonnen
mcdonell will bei den zwischenwahlen
2024 moderate kandidaten gegen
trappisten durchsetzen
wir sind zu besuch bei salomon vize chef
des landesverbands ohrringen der trump
ist ist fest davon überzeugt dass die
demokraten die gewalt vom 6 januar nur
als vorwand für ein anti-terror-gesetz
nehmen wollen um jagd auf republikaner
zu machen
das ist ihr anal wenn man eine
friedliche demonstration die aus
vielerlei gründen auch durch
provokateure schief gelaufen ist zu
terrorismus erklärt hughes landesverband
nennt abgeordnete die im kongress in
washington für das im pitch mit stimmten
vertreter der sechste januar mutter als
false flag operation bezeichnet und mit
dem reichstagsbrand 1933 verglichen
vor allem provokateure der linken antifa
hätten die gewalt mit entfacht das
benutzt die andere seite als
rechtfertigung für gesetze wie nach nine
eleven um uns unsere bürgerrechte weiter
weg zu nehmen wenn man so massiv fragt
man sich warum
deshalb haben wir das in verbindung
gesetzt mit dem was hitler mit dem
deutschen parlament machte bekommt für
seine thesen viel zustimmung aus anderen
landesverbänden an diesem tag im januar
auf der bühne am weißen haus zeigte der
trump ist muss sein wahres sein
finsteres gesicht als donald trumps
anwalt rudy giuliani gerade fertig war
da ging es im eingespielten video um
weltverschwörung finstere mächte in
hollywood den vereinten nationen dem
europaparlament
joe biden als marionette der juden der
linken im kongress antisemitische
rassistische hetze professor stanley hat
das herz video genauestens analysiert
der tramp ismus seien nichts anderes als
purer faschismus bewegung die mit
antisemitismus spielt so das ist nicht
nur faschismus sondern eine art und
weise von faschismus das so ähnlich wie
nationalsozialismus erst und und als
kind zwei überlebender vom holocaust
überlebender ist das macht es mir sorgen
und die amerikaner vor allem die weißen
werden als opfer dargestellt
[Musik]
donald trump als retter als oberster
befehlshaber
als ihr führer der führer befiehlt an
diesem tag den kampf
wenn ihr nicht wie der teufel kämpft
habt ihr kein land mehr und sie folgen
beweisbilder für das wesen des tramps
muss
auch deshalb stimmten sieben
republikanische senatoren für schuldig
einige wurden dann von ihren
parteigremien abgemahnt und trump macht
stimmung gegen sie
das könnte gefährlich werden so wie
schon für gabriels sterling als
wahlleiter von georgia bekam der
republikaner todesdrohungen weil er die
wahl joe biden beglaubigtes belastete
meine eltern und meine verlobte mehr als
mich jemand fragt er ob ich schon auf
dem normalen level von todesdrohungen
angelangt sei eigentlich sollte normal
sein
aber so weit sind wir noch nicht es
werden weniger mit der zeit seine partei
wird zur gefahr für die demokratie in
arizona wollen die republikaner per
gesetz dem parlament das recht geben das
ergebnis einer präsidentschaftswahl
einfach zu überstimmen und die gop in
texas nutzt den slogan der kanon
verschwörungstheorie wir sind der sturm
viel gewählte politiker und das ist wohl
in allen demokratien so sind
eingeschüchtert von ihren wählern bis zu
einem gewissen grad ist das okay aber du
wirst für dein urteilsvermögen gewählt
und um menschen zu führen wenn sie
getäuscht werden musst du ihnen den
rechten weg und die wahrheit zeigen aber
das ist offenbar der weg den die
republikanische partei weiter einschlägt
ein weg den donald trump quasi vom
golfplatz aus vorgibt weil sein angriff
auf die amerikanische demokratie
ungestraft bleibt